GDP roughly about a 243 billion dollars
the second largest economy in Africa
after South Africa at current growth
rates may overtake South Africa in the
next decade or so a country of 167
million people very good demographics
forty-two percent of the economy's
agriculture then another fifteen percent
or so it's all in gas and then you've
got services and hosted a retail trade
growth has been driven largely by the
non-oil sector all continues to play a
major role as the major source of export
earnings and also a major source of
government revenues the major challenges
are improvement in agriculture
productivity they need to diversify
revenues away from oil and which is
dependence on all as far as government
is concerned and for instance is
concerned and to strengthen the
financial system and deepen financial
markets there's a need for the
government to fast-track the work it's
dinner and cultural transformation
moving up the value chain Nigeria is the
world's largest producer of cassava for
example but we do not export any starch
or ethanol we export our crude oil and
we do not refine it significantly all
the refineries do not meet local needs
to import a lot of refined petroleum
products we import food from Asia like
rice for example and therefore the need
to work on a cultural transformation
they need to work on the petroleum
industry bill to attract investments
into downstream and petrochemicals that
work has been ongoing for a number of
years
the Nigerian banking system was hit by
the second round effects of the crisis
the crash in the price of oil basically
sub the quality from the system led to
crash in the stock market and the bands
that we're heavily exposed to the stock
market into the whole sector we're about
to fall and then they're about thirty
percent of the banking industry so we
did have to remove management we had to
prepare basically persecute some CEOs
and put some of them in jail we put in
money into the bank certified as a Roman
cooperation to recapitalize the banks to
force mergers and consolidation of the
banking industry we've broken up
universal banking however to introduce
very strict governance rules limiting
the terms of CEOs and the tenets of
religion directors and that's an ongoing
process we do think that the heart of
the problem was corporate governance and
risk management and that handles of
issues that we address it
a lot of shopping and culture at the
moment to the opportunities for growth
are just tremendous and the attempts at
the moment to build a cultural
infrastructure to provide incentives for
foreign investments to provide access to
market and to basically fix the value
chain and are amazing whether it's cocoa
or rice or sorghum or tomato and a
number of investments have already gone
I think we've had about eight billion
dollars go in in the last one year now
you've got also significant
opportunities in the oil and gas
industry when the petroleum industry
bill is passed this is not just about
exploration and production but also
refining petrochemicals gas basic
industries like fertilizer this is a
country of 167 million people that is
significantly imported dependent so the
opportunities exist for basically
setting up basic industries that produce
consumer goods for for that population a
number of political advantage of that